okay what we're going to talk about
today
is how to apply and succeed
at yc um in my capacity as the head of
admissions
i go around the world and i give
talks and i meet folks that are applying
and i answer lots of questions
and so i think i have a decent internal
model of the kinds of questions that
people have
and the kinds of things that people get
hung up on and so i'm going to do my
best
to anticipate what you're probably
thinking about and try to answer those
to the best of my ability
all right so why is it even worth
applying to yc um people ask this
question a fair amount of time
and i would argue that the very act of
completing the application
forces you to think about stuff that you
should definitely think about
um for instance
you know what are we building
what is different about what we're doing
than other options on the market
who are your competitors that's going to
want to ask
here's one that sometimes people don't
talk about before filling out the
application
what is your equity split you'd be
surprised people often have never had
that conversation
and so the very act of going through and
doing an application
and working with your co-founder to
answer all these things i would argue
is an extremely good idea and regardless
of whether you do i see again
you should have you should ask
yourselves all these questions
and if you find a bunch of murkiness
where you can't answer them
that's usually a sign that it you should
be discussing this more
and so right off the bat i just i
recommend
going and answering the questions i
think it's a good idea another thing is
if you are watching this very
presentation there is a good chance
um that yc is a great fit for you
right there's lots of people that apply
and they don't really know what yc is
and they googled like
how to get free money on the internet or
something um
[Music]
trust me i read these applications and
it's clear that they don't exactly
understand
what yc is and what it's all about they
just want money right
um that is not you you are here you've
been participating in this you have
there's lots of context that you have
um about yc and so that out of the gate
means you're going to be much better
prepared to fill this application
um and that you're a great fit for the
sort of company that we would want to
fund
okay another thing is i think a lot
about
what you should be doing as a founder in
terms of cost benefit analysis on time
there's a lot of things that seem like a
good use of time that are not a good use
of time
and there's a lot of things that may not
seem like a good use of time that are an
excellent use of time
and so i'd argue fill in an application
should really only take you i don't know
two or three hours
and the potential upside is quite huge
versus other ways you can spend two or
three hours where the upside is
is not much at all um so let's talk a
little bit about how you create luck
and this is sort of like a meta point
outside of the
application thing but great founders
create luck and there's ways that you
can create luck in your life
that increase the chances that you will
get lucky and the way you get lucky is
you set yourself up to be lucky as often
as possible
and so if you can set yourself up so
every single day of your life you have a
shot
it's something really fortunate
happening to you the odds that something
really fortunate will happen to you
is like super high and i would argue
applying to yc is definitely one of
those things
right um i answer questions and
invariably people will probably ask me
questions at the end of this
that are some kind of a complicated way
of being like of you talking yourself
out of why you should do it for some
reason that is not a great way to create
luck
and the fact is you're going to set
yourself up um
to be rejected all the time as a founder
right you
get customers your customers unsubscribe
from your service
um your customers are not happy you're
gonna try to recruit people that may not
work
you know you're gonna be told no all the
time and so
if you set yourself up if so that you
never hear no
and that you never get negative feedback
it's just like not
you're not gonna set yourself up to
actually be successful so this is an
example like when i talk to people when
i'm on the road
um a lot of the questions or concerns
that people have are all stem from this
which is they're afraid of what happens
if they don't get in and so they don't
even bother to take the chance
and again regardless of what i see in
this particular topic
i really think this is a good trait for
you to develop as a founder
we work on this in the program with
people of really encouraging people to
not be so afraid
of getting told no and systematically
trying to set yourself up for good
things to happen to you as much as
possible
right and so this is just another of
those situations
so let's talk about some of the reasons
that people don't apply
this one is very common i am too early
there is no such thing as too early
um we fund people
sometimes in the extreme case people
have changed their idea between when
they get invited to interviews and when
they get to the interview
that's an extreme case that's pretty
early
we also fund people that end up pivoting
mid-batch and so
that means they've been working on their
startup like a negative number of days
right that is clearly not too early also
and so again there's this
there's a lot of ideas around there that
like the right way to apply to yc is to
wait till you have a certain amount of
stuff
someone asked me a question what's the
right amount of mrr to get into yc
and like holy cow the answer is zero
right that doesn't mean you will
definitely get in every time clearly
but any kind of roadblock you put for
yourself that you're too early
i would argue is your own
self-constrained roadblock not something
that's coming from us
conversely people think they are too far
along and this one is great because it's
like uh
there's like this ideal point between
too early and too late that is like
last you know a week or something and
otherwise you're too far on either
extreme
um most likely you're not too far along
we have folks every batch that come in
we have folks that um
man had over a million dollars in annual
recurring revenue
um folks that have had 20 or 30
employees
uh folks that have raised a fair amount
of money like whatever metric by which
you think you too far and again maybe
you are genuinely too far
because you're like got a thousand
employees or something
um the odds are though most of the
people ask this question
it's because they are launched or um
they have a little bit of revenue and
they're like oh wow we don't need yc we
got it all figured out
and again our data and the folks that we
worked with suggest that you are most
likely not too far along depending on
your circumstance
so if that is the idea don't put the
barrier into yourself on why you're not
going to apply just cause you think
you're too far along
i'm too experienced this is where either
you just oh yeah i went to business
school or i've done a startup before
okay that's fine but all you're doing is
we're limiting
possibilities there and i don't there's
lots of folks that are super experienced
uh justin khan did yc three times um and
is now the founder of atrium
and he gets something out of it every
time and clearly he's very experienced
and i would argue
much more experience than many people
that think this about themselves so
again this is just creating barriers for
yourself
this is a common one there's something
specific about my company
that yc just doesn't get and um usually
the way that i answer this
is by listing all the types of companies
that we fund um
it is too long and too boring to list
here so i will not attempt to be
um to list them all but look whatever
industry you're in whatever you're doing
most likely we fund something kind of
like it or equally crazy to that and we
really like
crazy and weird things and again why
don't you make crazy weird i don't know
we've funded nuclear fission and nuclear
fusion startups and supersonic jet
startups
and like i don't know all sorts of crazy
biotech stuff so there's
it's unlikely that we're just going to
be like wow that's that's too weird for
us maybe
maybe you are that one but most likely
this is a barrier you're putting in for
yourself
this one's also really common people
think if you do yc you have to live in
the bay area
forever that is not true a huge
percentage of people that we fund
you know you do the program here but
that's three months then you go and do
whatever you want
right so if you're if you're super
worried about like wow i just love new
york city that's my home i want to be in
new york city
okay that doesn't preclude you from
wanting to apply to yc
okay there's more um i'll go through
this quicker i'm a solo founder
okay that's not a reason not to apply
it's just again maybe you're afraid of
rejection or you know that we encourage
you to have co-founders that doesn't
mean that's not a reason to not apply to
yc
um i've already applied to yc once
before i'll address this later but
just because you didn't get in once in
no way means that you won't do it again
so that's like
not a good reason i've already raised
some money i don't know the stats off
the top of my head
but a huge percentage of last batch had
already raised a few
you know on the order of six figures and
there's definitely some
seven figures as well and so in no way
does it preclude you from applying to yc
it's in fact extremely common um finally
there's competitors
sometimes they're you know if you're
doing like a self-driving car startup or
a scooter or startup or something
there's other folks that we funded in
the space
we we fund folks in the same space all
the time this does not preclude us from
funding you
nor is a good reason to not to not apply
okay
here there's not many but i do think
there is a couple of good reasons to not
apply
one is you can you have the kind of
business that is either not
anticipated to be fast growing enough
nor in your ambition is something that
ever makes sense to raise venture
capital for
and if that does not make sense for you
then yeah you probably shouldn't apply
to yc
like you should not raise any venture
capital you should make the growth rate
work for you and make the business model
that works for you and that's a-okay
right so no sweat that's a good reason
the other thing is
you're just not sure you want to work on
this very long all right that's that's
also a valid reason
um we're used to working with people
that are working on something very long
time
and so if you just want to do something
for a few months or uh put this on your
resume then yeah that's that's a fair
reason to not apply
how to apply okay this is really
straightforward
there's a website you go to the website
and you follow the instructions um it's
okay to apply
early or late depending on your
circumstances as jeff said
um there are
uh it's slightly harder to get in
earlier late and that's just because
we're not
that's not our primary time to be
cycling through things um
but if that's what if those are the
circumstances you're in um you should
definitely apply
this is a very common email question we
get is hey it's two weeks after the
deadline can i still apply
guess what the answer to that question
is it's a very quick yes
but people want to ask they want
permission and again this is a recurring
theme about founders you need to learn
you don't have to ask permission for
everything you don't need our approval
to do anything
you know there's a website if there's a
button where you can apply you should
totally apply
right you don't need to email us have a
say yes and then do it that is an
unnecessary step
right um so just keep that in mind um
and you can just email us
and again most of these questions are
just people asking should i apply and
our answer is almost invariably yes
but if you want to ask us you can
there's the email address
so let's talk about what makes a good
application
the first one i promise this is not
redundant
this matters and it's because i read so
many applications
i have a very good idea of what they
actually look like and i realize that
this talk will go on the internet and
many of the things that i say will be
reflected back like i'm creating a
feedback loop for the things that i read
and so things i'm putting in here are
actually meant like i want these ideas
to get dispersed of people knowing what
makes a good application because i think
that will make my job easier
right so this is very intentional the
first thing
is that you would be shocked how many
people don't actually fill out the dang
thing properly
like sloppy sloppy sloppy right there's
like whole areas where they don't
answer the question whatsoever they
don't put in urls they don't fill out
their bio
i don't know it's again it's not a very
long application you'll see yourself
but it is shocking to me how what a high
percentage of the time people just like
don't fill the dang thing out or like
put in lots of like errors and it's just
like
not great think about it about you know
applying for a job or any other kind of
professional thing
lack of professionalism here not equated
with success
so just fill it out it's that simple and
that's why i'm leading with this is you
would be shocked how few people follow
this direction
maybe they think it's like a lottery
ticket where they put it in an
application and it's a bad one they
might get in
no humans read these things i read these
things and i appreciate it if you fill
out the application
the second thing is the founder video
you would be shocked
how many people don't follow the dang
directions
there's directions on how to do the
founder video i.e it should be a minute
long
all the founders should be in the video
and people
don't do that we get the 20 minute
like spirit journey video
where i don't even know what they're
taught you know it's just like it goes
it's yeah or like sometimes i've seen
like an hour 20 i've seen some weird
stuff
but like the 20 minute spirit journey
video not super helpful
and i'm not it's really hard to sit
there and watch something for 20 minutes
um one minute is a perfect amount of
time we give you examples
those examples are great videos be like
that video um it's also really good to
have
the entire founding team in the video
people are always like hey
i'm here and i'm in the airport and my
co-founder is in here so here's my video
and like i think that's fine if that's
what you have to do
but maybe just waiting a couple of days
till you can be with your co-founder to
do the video would be a good idea
because my theory is a lot of times when
people don't follow the directions and
maybe because their co-founder doesn't
know they're replying to yc
like there's all these things under the
hood where the lack of the co-founder in
the video
speaks volumes um and so maybe
maybe you are have a great reason why
your co-founder is in the video but
i would suggest it right just and it's
in the directions
so i'm not telling you anything that's
not in the directions i'm just letting
you know yes we watch these things
and yes it's valuable and if you just
follow the directions then we're going
to be super happy
and when it's like either there's no
video or the video is weird another
thing that people do a lot is they put
in
like an unrelated video of a product
demo that they made with one of those
free tools where there's no humans in it
and it's like
i can't even describe it but anyway
there's a whole genre of things that
people put in there that are not
remotely following the directions
so please follow the directions i swear
it matters
clarity of thought this is a good
application
is easy to understand what they're
talking about and it doesn't mean you
write tons and tons and tons of words
tons of words can definitely has a
diminishing return where we don't know
what you're talking about and it's
i just can't understand what the
application is saying
also clarity on who's building the
product it's remarkably obfuscated
to even figure out what's going on and
who's even building the thing
like you'll see who the founders are and
you'll kind of see what they're working
on
but it's really hard to tell who's
building it and so just having it be
very crisp
of who's building it um again this is
this would put you way better than
average
if you just do these things it's so
simple right
so good applications do these
let's talk about clarity because this is
definitely something that
uh is worth talking about great
applications
that i read the application when i read
an application and i know when i read it
they're going to get in
they're super easy for me to read it
does not require a lot of work it
doesn't feel boring or painful
it just reads like with no effort
whatsoever
um and it's because i understand there's
no jargon
and everything just adds up and it's a
great narrative and
it's like wow what a great application
and you move on it's very quick
um weak applications
obfuscate they obfuscate
everything what is your idea
obfuscated what who's on the team who's
writing the code
obfuscated how does it work i have no
idea
what is the state of the company are you
launched do you have users what is it
you have revenue but you're not launched
what is that like
like basically it's like a puzzle you
pre when i'm reading one of these
applications
it's like a brain teaser where i'm
trying to figure out what's going on
and i promise this doesn't help i think
a lot of the times that people
obviously is they either think that
that's what we want to read or we like
buzzwords or we like this stuff
or they're trying to hide something
where it's not
we're like the revenue is actually their
personal salary but it's not revenue for
the company but they're putting it in
there because they think they should
have revenue like
stuff like that and so we'll ask
questions sometimes to figure this out
but there's such a clear delineation for
me as an application reader
about someone that is clearly
communicating in a very crisp way
versus where it's this brain teaser and
i'm trying to pull out
or it's just like tons of work for me to
pull out the key facts from the
application
okay um
and i think this is broadly applicable
if you're trying to convince someone to
buy your product or you're trying to
convince someone to work with you or
you're trying to convince an investor to
invest in your startup
and they don't even understand what
you're talking about you have already
lost right simply going for
coherent understanding should always be
the first thing you do before you're
trying to sell someone
right so if i don't understand what the
heck is going on in your application
it doesn't even get to the point where
it's like hey should we fund this
company or not we just don't know what's
going on
and you will notice that other people
will check out like if you're trying to
pitch your thing to someone
they can't follow you there's no way
you're getting them to yes and so i just
think this is such a broadly applicable
skill and something that we work on a
lot in the batch
is simply being clear and making sure
the other party
knows what you're doing first and then
selling them comes second
once they actually understand what
you're doing
so i put in a few examples here so
here's some examples of
really great descriptions from real yc
applications from world yc companies
that got in and so here's a company
called remix
and this is the entirety of their answer
to this question
there's not more this is it um
i don't know i'm not gonna read it um
out loud but like
it's what three sentences and i read
that and i know exactly what they do
and i know who wants it and that's it
great seems valuable right this requires
so little mental
effort to pull out what remix is and
what they're doing
and who it's for that i'm like great
like takes two seconds to read
okay
here's another one for a company called
tetra science also excellent
or a software platform that connects
scientific tools to the cloud it allows
scientists to access their lab device
from anywhere
blah blah blah and we make a heart small
hardware module
which connects those labs to the web
that's it
that's great that's what we want to read
see super chris
understandable no jargon answers all the
key questions
notice they're not trying to sell us on
any of this they're just explaining what
it is
and that's why this is so great is it's
super coherent super clear
here's another example from git lab when
they applied to yc
and they explain exactly what it is the
history of the company and they also add
in
really impressive facts right at the top
over 100 000 organizations use it
including
thousands of programmers at apple all
right that's good
glad they put that in there right and
it's right at the top super crisp
right so this is when we read these
applications it's very clear what they
do and we're like wow tell me more
like i understand what you're doing
here's an example of a bad one and i
didn't pull this from a real application
i wrote this myself and i wrote this
based on many of the applications i read
you know what i'm saying like i didn't
have to think too hard to write what a
bad
description is um and it keeps going i
couldn't fit it on the slide
it keeps going for pages
and this isn't even an exaggeration this
is what a lot of applications are like
and i understand like i have empathy for
the people that
apply with stuff like this because i
think that they think
that this is what we want or they think
that if they use enough jargon or
buzzwords
that we will get confused and fund them
or something you know it's like
stunning us like oh i don't know
blockchain okay yes
instead this is arduous work that makes
me
like want to go take a break i'm like
okay well i'm done
like i read one of these and i need to
go like get a breath of fresh air
um this is a really hard to read it's
really hard to understand what's going
on
and i still don't know i read this and i
i've learned nothing i still don't know
what this company does even after
reading the application
and so please don't apply
with stuff like this it's not helping
makes sense yeah and you do you see the
crisp difference between this
and the good examples yeah okay
um great applications tell a story
so here's the things that i would want
to pull out of an application that i was
reading
um who is on the team so this is who we
are
this is what we're working on this is
why we're working on it this
ie how we got the idea something like
that this is what we've accomplished
thus far
even if that's hey we haven't done much
that's okay i still
want to figure that out and this is why
we're going to make this work
and that's pretty much it these are the
things that i when i read an application
that i'm trying to pull out of it
and there's nothing fancy here and if
you make me work
really really really hard to figure this
out that's a scientific not a great
application
but if this just flows out without
taking any effort whatsoever then that's
a good application
nothing fancy here right and if you've
ever hired people and read resumes
before it's kind of the same deal
right you just look at a resume and
you're like okay cool there's some key
things you're looking for and then
you're like sounds good and you move on
right a resume that takes tons and tons
and tons of work
to make sense of is probably not a great
resume
okay here is my number one tip to
applicants
on what would help
make it clear that there's at least one
person on the team
who can make the thing that you are
working on
and notice i'm being a little vague in
that language because this is not
just software this means any kind
of technology that you bring to bear
right so if you are building a cure for
cancer you clearly are not going to have
any programmers on that team
nor would you be expected to do so but
it would certainly be good if you're
working on a cure to cancer
to have some sort of scientist on that
team does that make sense
um same thing hardware you know our
nuclear companies there were no
programmers that were the
founders of the nuclear companies but
you would hope to see a couple
of uh folks with phds and something
related to the nuclear field
right um so some sort of domain
expertise
and the reason is um we
we fund lots of startups and if you have
all these great ideas and no one on the
team can actually
do it you're going to have a hard time
um and so just having a really good
sense
both in the application and in general i
would recommend having someone on the
team that can
do it is highly recommended
and changeable
sometimes there's folks where the team
does is not
say you are working on something in
software and there aren't folks
that have the credentials or background
where
they're known software experts that's
a-okay we still
fund folks like this but the burden of
proof
is on them to prove they can do it i can
think of an example of a company where
it was like a self-taught programmer um
that was so
excited and wanted to do their idea so
badly that they went and built the
prototype themselves
and it was in the application like here
i milled this built this myself
great they got in right um and it's
because
the burden of proof not just like let me
take your word for it but you were able
to show
even though you don't have a background
of an established software engineer
you built a prototype and you brought it
to market and you proved it
and so that's a good way to think about
if you're in this
status of having a currently
non-technical team of just simply
backing up the fact that you can bring
the market you can bring the product to
bear whether that's from a team
whether that's you learning from
yourself
whether it's a friend helping with a
prototype just some evidence that you
can bring the product to market is
highly recommended
um and like last note here
is obfuscating this doesn't help
right so sometimes people make it very
vague who
built the product or where the prototype
came from or who's going to build it and
like
i don't recommend obfuscating this i
think having to be super crisp
on who is making the thing that you're
working on is highly recommended
okay if you have an application that
actually follows the directions
really well and is well written and does
the video stuff correctly
and you have one or more folks that can
build the thing that you want to build
and there's some evidence that you're
serious about it and what i mean by that
is
um just like a lot of times people apply
and it's clear they did it kind of on a
whim and they're not actually serious
about it whatsoever
it comes across if there's just some
evidence that you really
want to do this um that's recommended so
if you if you meet those things
um you get about a four times higher
odds to get an interview
right like if you're doing this stuff
getting an interview is not that crazy
hard
um and if you're not if you fail all
these criteria then yeah the odds are
are pretty slim and so it's as simple as
this
that this is you know
this is the pro this is what it looks
like to get an interview is that you
meet these criteria and again it's
pretty straightforward and transparent
okay
let's talk about applying more than once
okay about a third of last batch
were companies that applied already in
the past and didn't get in
and so the reason i say this is
it's not bad to apply and not get in
that doesn't ruin your odds if anything
it helps you
the way it helps you is that your next
application shows progress
if if you apply and don't get in and you
apply again and you show progress
i look at that when i'm reading the
applications and i know we all do
and we're like wow way to go they really
went and did it
like i'm so psyched like they went from
an unlaunched idea and then the next
application they launched it
wow great job you know like we're we're
impressed and this is another thing to
think about
is as application readers we're like
on your side we're not looking at
reasons to pick something apart
we're looking for evidence that like
you're serious and that like things are
going well and you're trying really hard
and so when you see someone expend real
effort and make real progress
application application
that's such a strong signal right and
this is why you see such a
huge percentage of the folks that that
do i see are folks that have applied in
the past
right is because it is such a strong
positive signal
one thing i wanted to mention is that
you it's basically impossible to network
your way into yc the whole reason yc was
created was to make it easy
for people that had no network to
start a startup and get help and raise
money and so
the idea of having this website where
you can apply and then you do a 10
minute review and you get funded
was like really out there and weird i
remember
uh when oic launched that i was not
working here
so we don't expect anyone to have a
network we don't expect anyone
to network with us um
one note on this is a lot i get the
sense it's not a lot of people
but some people attempt to cold email
us a lot or do other things that are
sort of stalkerish
a lot and that does not help
we don't expect you to have done that
and the vast vast vast vast vast
majority of people that get in are
complete strangers we have never met
before
that's the entire system here is funding
complete strangers and
my guess is your time is better spent
actually making your startup better
than trying to like do some weird stuff
to like get attention like we always
have these really crazy
attention-syncing things that happen
and i can assure you we don't enjoy
those things
um again what do i mean like people
email uh email they
physically mail us weird stuff sometimes
and like that's not
great right so sometimes some some
people put a lot of effort into this not
a lot of people some people do
and i'm just letting you know that this
is not a good use of time
um nor expected in any way and that's
not how i see a setup
another thing to think about is
sometimes there are people you know in a
network say
alumni or other people
and they will give you well-intentioned
bad advice um
for instance oh don't apply until you
have 5k mrr
or oh you know let me i i'm really tight
with the yc partners so let me put in a
good word for you or like
you should be very skeptical of this
stuff um self-appointed
people that are giving you
well-intentioned advice
that's essentially putting up barriers
between you and the process
i would just be like really wary of that
i'm sure it's coming from a good place
but
again a lot of times when i answer
questions for people that applying some
of the weirder ideas
come from people that are vaguely in the
network and so if someone's telling you
you're too early or too far along or
something something something i would be
fairly skeptical
right and again you don't need a network
to get in so
expecting the network to give you all
the perfect device is not always great
real real quick point this is not about
yc but this
the last topic you think of it watch out
for predatory advisors
so in the entertainment industry there's
lots of people that want to be famous
there's lots of people that want to be a
recording artist or they want to be
actors or directors
there's a huge supply of them and one of
the things of starting out in the
entertainment industry
is you meet all these people that claim
to have great connections
and they're somehow going to extract
value from these poor naive people
and it's really sad and this exists for
sure in the tech industry
where there are people that will just
ask for equity or cash compensation and
claim
all the stuff and promise you the world
and
it's kind of a drag to see this exist
and so i just want to encourage everyone
to be very wary of people like this
and to do research and that means
googling them if they claim fantastic
things look into that
due diligence on other people they
worked with in the past
there's just like a whole variety of
people that claim to help you break into
silicon valley
that i think is pretty dubious and there
are some legit things in there
but just like in the entertainment
industry for every
i don't know 10 people that claim they
can get you a meeting with
the head of all the labels to get you a
record deal you know
nine of those are probably lying you
know so
keep in mind the best way to have great
things happen is to build a great
startup and then
great folks will find you and to be a
little wary of some of the
some of the folks that are looking for
people just like you that are trying to
break in
all right so let's talk
about interviews um
if you get invited to interviews they
last 10 minutes
the interviews are in person we expect
the full founding team to be there
um there's usually three to four people
from yc in the interview
and the questions are usually very basic
and what we're trying to do is just
understand the nuts and bolts of the
business
it's nothing fancy just like i was
saying about the application process
people are surprised to learn that
there's nothing too fancy here there's
no trick questions there's no
um really expert stuff we're just trying
to understand really basic things like
oh
are you launched well how are you
getting users okay what is the next step
for the company how do you see this
getting big
these are all very very basic questions
and we're simply trying to understand
the stuff right versus um
yeah actually let me go to the next
slide so
there's a lot on the internet about how
to prepare for interviews
and i think a lot of it is a little
wrong
and the reason it's wrong is i think it
sets up the mentality that a yc
interview is this adversarial thing
that it's your job to beat right it's
like the interviewers are your opponents
and your job is to go in there and like
stun them and confuse them
and then if you fool us good enough then
we will fund you
and i think that that is wrong
um and i i again i read this whole genre
blog post because they're entertaining
to me
um and i think it's usually people that
didn't get in that write that and so i
understand how i can feel adversarial if
you didn't get in
and it's also more exciting to write a
blog post about this really exciting
interview and it was like they were
grilling me so hard and i like
had to think on the fly like that's more
exciting than yeah we had a kind of a
boring conversation about my business
right and so i want you this is a good
thing for
any kind of working with investors i
want you to put yourself in the shoes
of the person on the other side of the
table which is what are we trying to get
out of the interview imagine you were
interviewing a company what would you be
looking for
you'd be looking for basic answers to
your question
and you'd be looking for having a
pleasant conversation
that this is someone that you want to
work with and that you're excited to
embark on their journey with them
right and so a lot of what i'm looking
for in an interview is like can i have a
productive conversation with this person
and if someone goes in there and like
spits out this like
memorized paragraph of text about
ai something that's like weird
that's not like an organic conversation
of someone you might want to work with
that's someone going in there that
clearly read way too many blog posts
and spent way too much time preparing
and is like kind of not understanding
the context of the conversation
which is hey like let's have a
conversation about your company
instead they're just like spouting
nonsense at us okay and i feel like
that's a consequence of people
reading too many blog posts about this
adversarial process
because the fact is when we fund a
company
we are now working really closely with
that company forever
the founders and your group they they
get your cell phone number they call you
all the time they text you all the time
like
these become people that are really
important member of your life and the
people that i fund
like they like this lasts a long time
and so i just want you to know from our
perspective
we're just trying to get a feel of like
okay like are we ready to
really work with this company and get
super involved and so
remember you know have that compassion
for the people on outside the table
um versus making it really like a
strange
situation where uh it feels
unnecessarily
um i don't know memorized and painful
for us on the other side of the table
um and again like i think sometimes
people try to manipulate the process
and i don't if we get any hint that
you're trying to do something
weird again that's not a great that
doesn't engender um
trust i think that's the word we're
looking for trustworthiness in a sense
that you're
we're we're getting to know the real you
and those things
so let's talk about a successful
interview interviews do go really fast
and they're intense
and the reason they're fast and intense
is we're trying to pull all the
information out of you quickly and
there's not a ton of time
and so it's not an attempt to trip you
up it's simply that that's
how much time we have and we're trying
to learn as much as we can
successful interviews the founders
demonstrate a mastery of their own
business
they can talk about what they're working
on they know their own numbers
they know how many users they have they
know what their plans are
they know what their equity split is
like all the things that are in the
application
they are like yeah i can talk about that
you know like oh i have a question when
you said this
about that in your application what did
you mean oh yeah i have an answer to
that
right like we're just looking for you to
clarify things that we may not have
understood from the application
um and so there's no such thing as a
correct answer right this is not a quiz
show this is not a
beat the interviewers at their own game
this is a legit we're just trying to
understand what you're doing
another thing is we know
how risky this is and we know how slim
the odds are in an interview are to
succeed
and so if you come in there being like
everything's great everything's perfect
i have it all figured out i'm confident
like we're definitely going to be
successful i promise like
okay that's not actually good like it
denotes a lack of self-awareness
and so again if you over practice for
these things and you think your job is
to come in there
and tell us how you have everything
figured out and you're a genius and your
whole team is geniuses
and like it's like you cannot lose not a
great sign
um in an interview right so a good idea
of what is hard about the business
and what the challenges are is expected
and recommended versus the things where
you do have you know where you do know
what you're doing
does that make sense so yeah like
overconfidence not necessarily
a great you don't see this in successful
interviews
um you see self-aware founders
if you are interviewed and not selected
we send an email with some feedback
usually the feedback
is focused on a single thing which is
what we are most
concerned about or not convinced about
in the interview and it's pretty
transparent and straightforward and if
you take that feedback
and you go work on it and you apply next
batch
and you show how you either disprove the
feedback or addressed it
that is highly recommended and that's
totally a great way to get into yc you
see what i'm saying
like sometimes people get these emails
and then you never hear from them again
or they like get really angry or
something and like argue with you
um but you can either prove it and show
that the feedback is invalid like
hey we're worried about your growth
strategy blah blah blah we'll go prove
it yeah we did grow here's what we did
we love that we'd love to be disproven
or hey you were right about the growth
strategy and so here's the changes we
made
that's great things to hear too and so
we um
that's a great way to take this feedback
into account is is demonstrate either
it was not valid or that you've
addressed it
applying to yc is actually really
straightforward and well documented
and intentionally so
so there are not a lot of secrets
and we're not looking for people to do
too much tricky stuff the more you can
just like stay
make it super clear tell a super clear
story like i talked about earlier
then you're going to do great and i
would also argue
the skills that you need to successfully
apply are broadly applicable to what it
takes to be a great founder
right if you're going to talk to
reporters if you're going to be talking
to
other investors if you're going to be
talking to employees or talk to
customers
having all the skills that we mentioned
earlier that you would want to see in an
interview
or an application i think are extremely
useful
okay and then final point
if you have questions and the question
is the form
should i apply dot dot dot most likely
the answer
is yes and just always think about and
reflect on if you're being the barrier
to setting yourself up to being lucky or
having fortunate things happen to you
and and optimize towards saying yes to
things like this
i think i think it'll help you in
general as a founder
great thanks so much
you